hello
welcome to candlelab my name is chris
today i will be discussing sample
preparation and provide a brief overview
of the potency methods
we recently developed using hplc
following this brief presentation i'll
share a video just
describing the basic steps required for
extracting cannabinoids from hemp flour
let's start by discussing the overall
potency workflow
this workflow consists of four basic
steps sample preparation calibration
chromatography and data analysis so what
are some of the highlights of this
workflow that
make it unique we offer step-by-step
instructions for sample preparation that
allow for the analysis of 17
cannabinoids
we've developed three different methods
depending on
your hplc instrumentation the first
being a rapid high resolution gradient
method
which is about six minutes on a c18
column
two two micron particle size the second
is a
rapid gradient method also about six
minutes on a c18 column of a larger
particle size
and the third method being a low
pressure isocratic
method which is about 8 minutes on the
ca column
all of our methods utilize low flow rate
for reduced solvent consumption
which leads to additional cost savings
and all of our mobile phases are
compatible with mass spectrometry
okay let's go over the basic steps
required for sample preparation
so the first step being homogenization
so we recommend homogenizing at least
five grams of hemp flour
using a cryomill is ideal because it
generates the least amount of heat and
it's known
that excess heat will break down some of
the cannabinoids
which will kind of skew the true
cannabinoid profile
next you want to weigh about 500
milligrams
of homogenized material transferred to a
container next we perform a series of
two ethanol extractions so
each ethanol extraction uses about 20 ml
of ethanol it's shaked for vortex for 30
minutes
and then centrifuge to remove the
soluble plant material
each extraction you're going to transfer
the soluble fraction to a 50 ml
volumetric flask and then once
the two extractions are formed you bring
it up to volume
with ethanol next you perform
a 110 and 1 100 dilution
with methanol and then next you filter
your sample
there's also the option of filtering the
sample after you bring up the volume in
the volumetric flask
the critical aspect of cannabinoid
analysis
is the preparation of your standards the
use of high quality crms is essential
for accurate quantitation of
cannabinoids
cerulean is an iso 17034 manufacturer of
crms
we offer a large variety of cannabinoids
in solution format
carefully optimized for the highest
level stability and ease of use
each product comes with a detailed
certificate of analysis
documenting the certified concentration
measurement uncertainty
and metrological traceability we're
constantly adding new cannabinoids
and be launching cannabinoid mixes
within the next few months
here's an example of how one might
prepare a standard mix containing the
six major cannabinoids
using the following dilution scheme
outlined in this table
a calibration curve spanning 0.25 to 100
micrograms per ml can be prepared
to accurately quantitate the major
cannabinoids in a sample
we recommend preparing standards in an
amber volumetric flask or
gravimetrically to ensure the highest
level of accuracy
and batched batch consistency
as i mentioned earlier we recently
developed three different hplc methods
that are capable of separating
17 cannabinoids all these methods
offer short run times low solvent
consumption and mass spec compatibility
additionally all these methods use the
same easy to formulate
mobile phases further reducing user
errors
this is example of the low pressure
isocratic method
on the census express ca column and is
compatible
with a conventional hplc system
using a gradient on the census breast
c18 column
we're able to achieve better separation
of delta 9 and 8
for a total of 17 cannabinoids in a run
time
of about 6 minutes
the rapid high resolution method offers
the highest level resolution
and is well suited for a modern uh plc
system
real real world testing has proven
consistent performance
across thousands of injections across
several matrices
this high efficiency column is well
suited for handling additional
cannabinoids in the future
should there be a demand for 17 plus
cannabinoids
using two of the methods i just
described the low pressure isocratic
and rapid high resolution method where
an orthogonal analysis
was performed on hemp flower sample to
determine the total thc
and cbd values both methods were capable
of quantitating the six major
cannabinoids
and also provided a profile of the minor
cannabinoids
the results from both methods were in
agreement providing further confidence
in the calculated total thc and cbd
values
so next i'm going to show you a video
describing the basic steps
required for extracting cannabinoids
from hemp flour
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so let's talk hplc instrument
configuration
this is not the most exciting or
appealing subject
but it certainly is relevant to you
maximizing your instrument performance
and for the methods you are developing
so let's jump right in so what we're
going to cover
first is instrument selection and column
selection and the two are interrelated
um and that's an important point to to
understand and
and and again i'll explain that further
we're then going to jump right into how
to actually improve the instrument
performance through the instrument
configuration
hardware configuration this is really
about minimizing system dispersion
although we're not going to go into the
theoretical discussion of of that we're
going to stick with sort of the take
home messages
and then um data collection there's uh
some parameters data collection that
need to be
attended to as well so that'll be uh
the the the contents of this talk uh not
very long
um pretty straightforward so let's get
started then with
instrument selection and column
selection so
why does instrument selection matter or
does it well
if you're going to attempt to use some
advanced columns uh
newer technologies uh that require you
know that you want i'm sorry that you're
going to want to
maximize resolution and throughput
instrument selection then does
definitely matter you have to pay
attention to that
if you're gonna be using traditional
columns um
and by that i mean uh columns that have
five micron maybe three micron fully
porous particles
instrument selection is likely not
critical particularly if you're using
five micron you're not going to have to
be concerned about that so it does
really depend on
what your strategy is around column
selection
in looking at your instrument options
you know whether this is
um what is of currently available to you
or maybe even if you're looking at
purchase
uh you have uh the sort of three classes
of instruments that you can think of
you have um options for um
the first excuse me is you know the
traditional hplc these were you know the
most
400 bar instruments as they were called
that's the maximum pressure
um though these were instruments that
were around you know
more than 10 years ago but you know you
can still find in labs you know
and i'm listing here simply just
examples it's certainly not
comprehensive but examples of typical
instruments in each category so with the
for the traditional hplc
probably the most common uh one in that
case is the agilent 1100
right and again just some other other
other ones of that same uh
generation as well listed there um
what if you're looking at new
instruments though you're probably
not going to be able to find anything
less than what i'm calling an advanced
instrument
here in other words i don't think
traditional hplcs are sold anymore
these are ones that have a higher
pressure limit 600 bar
you know again one that came out that
was very popular of course because
as just an iteration of agilent's
product line was the agilent 1200
there's the samadzu lc20 which was you
know also had the name prominence that
was um
fairly popular um and then there's the
uh plcs these are instruments that can
can deliver you know back pressures
in excess of a thousand bars or at least
a thousand bars and you know
the waters acuity you know is probably
the first one on the market and again
here are just a couple other popular
ones
um that uh you you frequently see the
thermo ultimate 3000 actually is
interesting because depending on how it
can be configured it can also be maybe
shifted down into the advanced
instrument it's it it's quite
configurable
um but others that are you know not
listed here i didn't have the room you
know the shimadzu lc30 or
now the lc40 the uh thermo vanquish is
their latest edition
um so yeah just think about sort of
these three different classes of
instrument
um and and because because this is i'm
going to be referring to this in terms
of column selection
and what i've also listed here um above
this
um below the headings is just sort of a
diagram
if you will a graphic of system
dispersion so that's really what has
evolved
here with the instrument evolution is is
designing
instruments that have smaller system
dispersion so as to take advantage of
higher performance columns
so you know when it comes to column
selection i need to touch on
you know particle technology um and
and as i just said this is limited to uh
particle
columns um there's the
the three to five micron porous fully
porous particles as what i
consider traditional columns now there
are other
uh smaller size fully porous particles
for sure that is gets you right into the
the high performance category but in in
the context of traditional columns we're
talking about three to five micron
porous particles with emphasis really
more of the five micron
because of the larger particles larger
as in five micron
um there is you know isn't the highest
resolution
and therefore also methods will tend to
be longer i mean that's a principle a
very fundamental principle that
efficiencies related to column length
because it's not the latest and greatest
technology
of course they're lower costs so you
know that's that's certainly an
advantage if you will
that's that's one of the the trade-offs
then though is performance
in contrast to that our three to five
micron
um you know core shell or superficially
porous particles and
in in our case in our product line is
the trademarked
fused core particles these are higher
performance
columns they're higher resolution and
therefore require
shorter methods and the real advantage
is that they deliver the highest
efficiency per unit pressure so
as this diagram shows you have you have
this
um outer porous shell thus the names
like
core shell or superficially porous in
which the material there has a porosity
just like the fully porous particles
but much of the volume of the particle
is actually
impermeable it's a solid glass for
instance
so it's only the outer layer that is is
accessible to solvent and thus the
analytes
so i wanted to give you
an example uh or show you how
this relates very much to column choice
in terms of what kind of performance you
can expect from a
given size column or given length column
i should say and the type of particle so
what you see on the lower um the lower
dash
gray dash line is the sort of the
performance you can expect for a 5
micron
fully porous particle this would be a
traditional column anything from 50
millimeters all the way up to 250
millimeters the 250 millimeter length is
not
uncommon for a five micron fully porous
particle
um then as we go up the next one to
these this
blue or blue and purple lines the solid
blue line and the dash purple line the
solid blue is the five micron
fused core particle columns the
the dash purple the three micron fully
porous particle
um so what you see right here and you
see above it as well
is that for a given performance of a
fully porous particle the equivalent
performance is a
a class larger particle size in the k
for the uh core shell or the fused core
it's usually the fused core particle
so what you're gaining is the
performance of the smaller
fully porous particle column but you're
only talking about the back pressure of
the larger size particle in this case
what i'm referring to is the 5 micron
likewise if we move up again you know
to get the sub 2 micron performance the
sub 2 micron fully porous particle
performance
you can use a particle that's almost as
big as a 3 micron
particle the 2.7 micron fused core again
the equivalent performance but at a
lower back pressure because it's a
larger particle
and then the the the top line then is
the you know the two micron or smaller
fused core columns so
what i want to show you then is if you
look at the the horizontal black
dash line that on the right side you
know it's
it intersects with the 5 micron fully
porous particle column
250 centimeter length again that's
that's not unusual
for that that sort of uh column
but if you follow that over to the left
you know where it intersects or comes
close at least to this
the five micron fused core column you're
even less than the 15 centimeter column
the 150 millimeter
column length so in other words you
could have a 150
millimeter length 5 micron fused core
column
and have equivalent or better
performance than the
5 micron fully porous particle column in
250 centimeter length so you've really
cut way back
on the run time at the same while
preserving or actually slightly
improving the performance
and you can you can go keep going
further to the left you know again
where it intersects the 2.7 micron
you know is less than um the
the 100 millimeter column length so you
could be talking about
a 2.7 micron fused core particle in a
100 millimeter length column and getting
equal to or better performance
than your 250 millimeter five micron
fully porous particle column and you ver
may very well be able to run that
certainly in an advanced instrument and
if you pay attention to
you know really optimize the
configuration of the traditional
instrument hblc instrument you may well
get it to work
you know quite well there as well so
this is a useful
chart to show you the comparative
performance of
these different particle technologies
related to column lengths
so then in thinking about uh how column
selection then influences instrument
selection
in terms of what kind of configuration
you're going to have to pay attention to
whether or not
you will need to i've divided this out
into these two
particle classes again the traditional
three to five micron particle column
versus the two to five micron fused core
columns and if you look
um first on the left for the traditional
particle the three to five micron
traditional particle
if for instance you're going to be using
a traditional
instrument and you want to use a a three
micron particle
you're going to very likely have to do
some reconfiguration of the instrument
you can certainly
want to look into it and check to make
sure that you're you're
at the best you can if you're going to
be using a five micron particle you're
good to go
on any of those instruments the
traditional the advanced or the uh plc
um in the case of the fused core columns
um
let's first consider for instance the
smallest
the two micron particle size uh in a
traditional instrument
you you do not want to go there because
you are going to simply have too high a
back pressure for one thing
that then what the the traditional
instrument can
likely deliver and you're just not going
to be able to even with optimum
configuration
given the the generation of instrument
that it is you're not going to be able
to configure that
reconfigure that to get the kind of
performance that you would expect out of
that small a particle column
however if you were to use such a column
say with the advanced instrument
you're going to want to check a few
things out on on the instrument
configuration to make sure everything's
good to go
um and with the uh plc again it's it's
it is good to go as is um the 2.7 micron
same sort of thing to take advantage of
the the
the potential performance of that
whether it's a traditional or
advanced instrument you're going to want
to take a look at
the instrument configuration which we're
going to talk about here in a moment
the uh plc uh it's good to go um
likewise then say with the five micron
fused core
um with a traditional instrument you're
going to have to pay attention to
even with that size particle to the
configuration of the instrument
so again you know if you think back to
the previous
that previous chart perhaps you know the
five micron fused core with a
traditional instrument
you're going to have to pay attention to
reconfiguration just like you would with
the
three micron fully porous particle with
a traditional instrument because those
two particles
have very similar performance right so
that all that all works together there
makes sense um with a five micro
micron particle with an advanced uh plc
you're definitely good to go
you might say well why in the world
would you do that well you know we're
not getting into that the point here is
simply that
that you wouldn't be need to be
concerned about any
optimization of reconfiguration in those
cases
where you see the check marks here
so let's get into this then and when
we're talking about
instrument reconfiguration what is it
that we need to do
to maximize the performance of your
instrument
so there are some simple modifications
you can do to reduce system volume and
for all practical purposes and i just
want to emphasize that for all practical
purposes you can think of reducing
system
volume as being equivalent to reducing
system dispersion
technically it's not i'm not going to
get into that
you would certainly be welcome to
contact me if you want to have further
discussions if you're curious about that
but just keeping it simple with some
simple things you can do there's three
things that that
that are relevant here one is tubing
length
excuse me and um you know that's
probably seems
pretty obvious i would say it is um
minimizing tubing length
and there's this linear relationship
between tubing length and tubing volume
um that's just you know related to the
volume of a cylinder
but one thing you can think about as
well here is also the physical
arrangement of the components of your
hplc you know
sometimes these are stacked vertically
sometimes they're not
even when they are stacked vertically
you know what is the sequence
that they are they're stacked in you
want to make sure that makes sense
in terms of minimizing the fluid path of
of the system so you would want to
you know whether you're going top to
bottom or bottom to top it doesn't
matter but let's say you're starting at
the top
you'd have your pump then you'd want
your auto sampler
then you'd want your column oven and
then your detector
okay so that way you can you can
physically get these components as close
together as possible
and minimize the tubing length the next
thing which again might seem
kind of obvious is to tubing diameter
it's interesting though that of course
um volume is a function of the square of
the diameter so for instance if you cut
your diameter
by a factor of two you cut it in half
you've reduced the volume of that same
length tubing by factor of four
all right so that's good but the
downside though is also
pressure is a function of the reciprocal
of diameter squared so
for instance if you cut your tubing
diameter by half your pressure is going
to go up by a factor of four
so that's where we have this trade-off
right we want to minimize
minimize that that volume of the tubing
but the trade-off is pressure we can't
get too high so
an ideal um tubing diameter is 100 to
125
microns so that's the equivalent of .004
inches id 2.005
and you do not want to go larger than
.005
and that's where this especially comes
in with with with
reconfiguration say of traditional
instruments those typically came with
tubing
of point zero zero seven two point zero
one
uh inch id or point zero one is 250
micron right
twice that of the point zero zero five
um so
that's where you you may end up having
to take one of those instruments and do
completely re-plumbing with some with
some tubing it's not that big a deal
though
um it's really pretty straightforward um
now again you know you gotta you gotta
consider
pressure ramifications but um the
outlet the column outlet that is the
tubing from the column to the detector
if that's not too long
you know it may be feasible to go to
something as small as 75 micron id
um there will be a you know considerably
higher back pressure but again if it's
not too long you may be able to take
advantage of that volume savings as well
lastly the one that is you know
potentially considerably more
expensive there's more investment has to
do with looking at the flow cell volume
so we're talking here about
optical detectors um what i'm showing
you here is just sort of a cross section
where you're seeing the
inlet this is the the tubing you know
coming from the column
the inlet into the flow cell
then the flow cell has a certain path
length and then there's the outlet
which would typically go to waste and
you have this these windows on either
side of this flow cell where the
optical beam is passed through for for
doing the absorption measurement
um so in traditional instruments
the um the flow cell volume was 10
microliters or sometimes even more
so again if you're going to be going to
fuse core
columns you're going to have to be
looking at putting in a different flow
cell in that case the maximum volume
you want to have in there is a 5
microliter flow cell
and the really the optimal is 3
microliters or less
again different options from different
manufacturers um
the the there's also a consideration
perhaps of the the
just the fluidics the design of this
which is something
um you know not all flow cells are the
same so that's going to be another
factor but it's not something that's so
much in your control
perhaps path length is though of course
this is linearly related to sensitivity
right
um so ideally you'd want to keep a path
length of what's
sort of a standard path length of um 10
millimeters
one centimeter so again two very low
cost
um modifications uh you can look at for
your instrument tubing length and tubing
diameter
the flow cell is very important but
that's that's
certainly going to cost you more if you
if you are going to be optimizing that
but again
you really can't avoid not looking at
this if you're going to really want to
go to the smallest particles that you
you could otherwise use
so the one other thing that you can't
overlook has to do with data collection
and there are two parameters of data
collection that
software controls this again is
configured in the software
for a method one the sampling rate and
the other is response time so
first let's look at sampling rate so the
top the top graph is sort of a
a a true signal trace
of a you have a chromatogram here
but you can control your sampling rate
and that is simply how many points per
unit time how many data points per unit
time this
the data system is acquiring so
what you need to do in order to optimize
um measurements optimize whether you're
looking at performance or
quantitation you know peak area you need
at least
10 data points across a peak um that
you should consider minimum um you could
go you can go as high as 20 you know
that's that's fine that's good i would
argue more than that and you're wasting
um you know you're getting too large a
file you get too too big a file you're
not gaining anything from that but
that's that's that's your you know your
choice but you know at least
at least 10 points across a a
chromatographic
peak so in the the middle chromatogram
there if you will the data points
collected
um the narrowest peak in this case is
the first one
um and we've only got uh five data
points there which is half of what we
really need so
in this case again sampling rate is too
low
um this also comes into play if you have
critical pairs right if you're not
collecting enough data points between
those peaks
things can start to merge there as well
and again as i mentioned you want to
determine
what minimum sampling rate you need for
your narrowest peak so for an isocratic
run that's going to be your earliest
peak
for a gradient method it's not
necessarily going to be so
straightforward you're going to have to
go and look through
you know all your peaks and find the
narrowest one to make sure you get at
least data
and data points across that and the
bottom bottom
um matagram you certainly that's more
than sufficient
in terms of a sampling rate all right so
the downside the other downside of too
high a sampling rate or a sampling rate
that's more than necessary is going to
be more noise
okay that's just one thing to keep in
mind um then there's the response time
again this is regarding optical
um detectors this you can think of is
how
quickly the detector responds to a
change in the signal
right so what you're seeing here is sort
of a worst case to illustrate the point
and when i say worst case i mean
a peak that is extremely narrow and so
what you see is in the
the fastest response time which is .05
seconds you're seeing
you're getting much closer to the actual
the true
chromatographic peak there when the blue
trace
but as you increase the response time
the signal
the measured signal actually becomes is
looks like it's shifting later and also
getting broader
again that's just simply from a delay in
how quickly the instrument the detector
is responding to the signal
and um you know just to say that you
know this was done as it shows here
at a 20 hertz sampling rate that's 20
points per second that was more than
sufficient
for this example but
you know as with sampling rate um the
real downside to do
doing having a response time that's
faster than necessary
is you get excess noise so again it's
something you want to have sort of
that's optimized more or less i can tell
you for an actual
you know real chromatogram you're
there's no way you need to go faster
than 0.1 seconds in fact for
you 0.2 seconds may be quite sufficient
again that's just something you you
would maybe want to
to try and just confirm that everything
looks good that way but
um yeah
so yeah uh summary uh what we talked
about here then
is um instrument selection and column
selection how they're interrelated you
know you've got to have the right
instrument and instrument configuration
for the type column you want to use
and and that's not so much about the
particle type but a combination of
particle type and particle size
and so likewise you know it goes the
other way if you have you know you know
you want to use a
the best column you can for your
instrument you also want to make sure
then of course that you have
the appropriate instrument for that
so yeah we talked about these column
technologies the choices and
implications the comparison of
performance between the two different
types
and then you know instrument
configuration you know focused on
minimizing system volume
to minimizing tubing length um
tubing diameter is critical
you have to you know take into account
the pressure considerations as well so
again i recommend
you know a 100 to 125 micron id for that
works very well for uh these fuse core
columns
and then also the flow cell um you want
to make sure the flow cell volume is not
more than five microliters
and we just uh discussed data collection
as well with sampling rates need a fast
enough sampling rate to make sure you
have at least 10 points across the
narrowest peak
and the detector response time needs to
be fast enough as well but again going
too fast uh only
causes more noise than and that's not
anything desirable of course
so with that i thank you very much
today my name is trisha schnelly and i'm
going to be taking the next
minutes to walk you through some hints
and tips for your cannabis analyses for
your high purity water
ultra pure water is highly prone to
contamination
and as the most frequently used solvent
in lcms
laboratories its purity plays a critical
role
in your analyses and so what we're going
to go over today are just a few
quick things you can do in the lab very
easily regarding your water storage
your glassware cleaning your consumables
and last but certainly not least
the usage of your water purification
system
so but before we dive into those tips
and tricks i do want to take a moment to
discuss
why contaminated why having contaminated
high purity water can be problematic
in your laboratory so first is
difficulties
in interpreting your data if you if your
water is contaminated you'll end up with
background noise in your chromatograms
it also can decrease the lifetime of
your columns
and increase the maintenance of your
instruments so we want to make sure we
avoid that but
to me most importantly it's the risk of
repeated experiments
which leads to waste of sample reagents
solvents
and time and we know that all of that
equals money
so to save money and to save time and
save your results
we want to make sure you're getting the
most out of your high purity water that
you can
so the first thing we're going to talk
about is your water storage
and so you may not think about water
storage as being an
issue but there's actually two places
where you can
you can see increased where you can
experience problems and that's actually
contamination from the environment
as well as contamination from the
container
these are two areas we're going to
discuss over the next couple slides and
demonstrate to you
why why these things need to be taken
into consideration
the first is avoiding repeated opening
of stored high purity water so when
you're storing high purity water over a
length of time and you're
you're opening the bottle and closing
the bottle and opening and closing
over a period of time you're exposing it
to those environmental contaminants
and so in this particular experiment we
took bottled ultrapure water and we
stored it for four weeks
and we used it we we opened it and
closed it like you would in any normal
laboratory situation and to replicate
that
and then here on the bottom we just use
freshly produced millicu
ultra pure water through our through the
lcms
and so you can see here from this this
top chromatogram which is the bottled
water you can see you have some peaks
and some background noise that you
certainly wouldn't want to have you can
see down here
um by using fresh water that you
actually
get rid of that background noise for
your experiments
so that's that's storing your water and
why
how the environment impacts it but you
may be asking well
how does the container i actually store
it in cause problems well
some people don't think about this but
plastic can actually be problematic for
storage of your high purity
water we recommend using brown glass
bottles
for your storage but people commonly use
plastic
carboys and things to store their their
water so we've
we've taken water and stored it in a
brown glass bottle and a polypropylene
bottle
and then took the water out of it and
did lcms to see
what kind of results we had and so here
we on the left we have
the brown glass bottle you can see no
peaks no background noise
you come over to the polypropylene
bottle you
get anti-static agent peaks you get
peaks from stabilizers
and then down here on the tic intensity
you can see
low level background from the brown
bottle but the higher level from the
polypropylene bottle so you can see that
that prop
polypropylene can leach
agents into your water that can cause
background
and so ultimately we just want to
remember
in when it comes to water storage just
use freshly purified water whenever
possible it will make your life easier
and take out some of that questions
about where some of those peaks may be
coming from if it's not what you expect
to see
so moving on we're next going to talk
about glassware cleaning
and the take home here is to avoid
dishwashers um
is our general rule of thumb within
within millipore sigma
and so we we actually in this study we
looked at
containers washed in a dishwasher versus
containers washed with acetonitrile
and ultra pure water and so you can see
we ran it through
our analysis and you can see here in the
washed and dishwasher you can see all
these
background peaks compared to containers
washed with acetonitrile and ultra pure
water
and we even identified some of these as
triton detergents
within these peaks so although
dishwashers
are incredibly convenient they do leave
residue
behind that can contaminate your water
so thus it's important
to wash your glassware correctly so just
always remember your container should be
carefully rinsed
to ensure that there is no detergent
residue that
contaminates your water
moving on we're then going to talk about
your consumable usage or your
your cartridges and filters and of
course we want you to replace those
um regularly and this is this is for
your your benefit to do this um because
it can
it can really impact your your
background noise and the purity of your
water
we also we also recommend you rinse your
new cartridges
following the user manual instructions
in case anyone's interested
our new um millicu iq
and ix 7000 series showed here
they have consumables that can be pla
replaced with one hand
so no more having the sign next to the
system
telling you how to change the consumable
because it's complicated
and in addition the user manual is
actually stored here on a touch screen
touch screen so you never have to go
digging through the drawer
drawer wondering where the manual is but
talking about these consumables and why
they need to be changed
um we we're going to look at
specifically final filters
at this point and so this is what a
final filter looks like
it is what is at the end of the the
point of use
um so it is like it's called it's a
final filter
um and in this situation what we what we
studied is we studied fresh ultrapure
water from a millicue system with a
filter that was relatively new
and then or within the time range we
typically
expect people to use these final filters
we actually
recommend they get changed every three
to four months and then
compared it to fresh ultra pure water
from a millicu system with an
old final filter and specifically 18
months old
and you may think that's crazy
considering we we recommend
every three to four months however 18
months is
not a crazy number we've actually seen
this
very regular regularly in laboratories
that we visited
and so this isn't a completely obscene
number
um and so we ran we ran this water
through a uh plc
system and you can see the chromatogram
here on the left
and you can see that with the ultra pure
water with the old final filter you get
this you get this random peak
and so obviously that can be problematic
to the work that you're
you're doing and so the take-home point
here
is change your cartridges and final
filters as recommended
we recommend those timelines for a
reason and the reason
is the that chromatogram on the that you
just saw
that can happen to you
and then last but certainly not least we
want to talk about
using your water purification system and
specifically about
when you come back on a monday from the
system not being used for a couple days
or if
if work has been down due to the
pandemic and you come back
after weeks of not using it this is even
more critical at this point in time but
what what we do here is we we really
recommend flushing
the water so in this particular study we
took
milliculture pure water on monday after
it was stood in standby
over the weekend and we ran an lcms on
it
we also took water from a millicue
system on monday
but discarded the first four leaders out
of the system
to do that flush and then have that
chromatograph down here and so when you
compare these chromatographs
you can see that using the water that's
in the system and not flushing it first
can cause some background noise that you
certainly don't want
whereas if it's fresh water after
discarding
you get no background and that's exactly
what you want to see
so as a reminder don't forget to flush
it's it's incredibly important to do
because you don't want to get any
contaminants
in your in your analyses
so i just want to take a moment and
review what we went over
i know it's not a lot but it's it's very
impactful and it's
been in a short period of time so make
sure you use fresh water whenever
possible
avoid dishwashers and carefully rinse
your glassware
change your cartridges as recommended
and flush your system
after periods of lack of use and so
that concludes this workshop today i
hope you
learned a little something maybe can
apply to your lab
and thank you so much for your time and
enjoy the rest of your day